[Music]
more talk tonight about the oakland days
and a move
out of the east bay perhaps to las vegas
ron futrell is in the newsroom with the
latest a-ron
kirsten tuesday is the day the oakland
city council
will vote on a proposal that they hope
would keep the
team in oakland now we got a sneak peek
at that proposal today
the mayor of oakland libby schaff she
loves it the oakland a's
do not this is what the proposed 12
billion dollar project
would look like in the east bay a new
baseball stadium is just part of it the
oakland
a's president dave cavell who has been
to las vegas many times now looking for
a new location here in town
for a new ballpark says today's planned
release
by oakland would not work for the a's he
says quote
we're really far apart end quote now one
of the major sticking points on the
project
the mayor wants the a's to pay 400
million dollars for affordable housing
units in the city
and the a's say the regulations in
california
make it very tough for them to work with
and they don't have those same
regulations here of course
in nevada recently minority owner of the
ace billy bean visited las vegas
ballpark and he really liked what he saw
i got to be honest with you the
facilities here are better than we have
in oakland i mean you know i mean it's
no secret that
you know we're trying to secure a new
state and we have an old stadium but the
facilities here i mean
when our guys get sent down to triple a
they're actually going up
in terms of the you know the playing and
the stadium
and so it it's really an amazing amazing
place
okay we agree the a's played an
exhibition game at las vegas ballpark
couple of years ago
it's possible they could play there
while a new stadium is being built
in las vegas the a's have looked at 20
potential sites here in town
the key here and this is the key of
course there is still no word
who would pay the one billion dollars it
would take to build a retractable dome
stadium here in las vegas cavall says he
is planning
another trip to vegas next week
following the tuesday vote by the city
but again the news today the a say the
proposal
the proposed that was released today is
one that they would not accept
next week we could see the a's ramp up
their efforts for a new home here
i'm ron futrell eight news now